hello reject nation
it's Greg Alva here Wow really
recovering from that fever I got a big
bottle of vitamin seeded in case I just
need a pop yeah so I just took a nap
sweat it a lot I started feeling better
so I was like all right time to watch
this next step so the flash so that way
I am up-to-date people I'm gonna be
officially caught up and then there's a
new episode tonight that's great by the
way in case you haven't heard the news
you can only show about ten minutes
worth of footage on YouTube and usually
it's a very specific thing that you can
show we do full TV show reactions over
our patreon patreon is really growing
right now so we love it if you guys
could go check it out over there it's a
lot of fun I love me the elongated
Knight Rises and the damn thumbnail and
CW gave away that freaking Ralph's Dib
knee gets his elongated Man suit in here
especially because it's called the
elongated Knight Rises you know it's
probably just giveaway MIT stuff right
there
[Laughter]
Wow Jim Carrey could have played this
guy the 90s I have the soup didn't burn
yeah Jim Carrey totally gonna play
damn who's this guy
whoa that was that was unexpected nice
really blowing this supervillain fight
well it's my Central City returns party
and your death may be a story
[Music]
your death will make me a star
[Music]
it's acid I call it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if there's one thing I've realized it's
behind every great trick isn't even
better
it's a trap they've got Caitlin and
Cisco gonna need this oh [ __ ]
[Music]
hey does that Bruce Campbell thing
[Music]
I told you the story
nice yeah
[Music]
we did lucky twice
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
much cooler paler now let everyone go
pranksters and no one gets hurt
see I thought I was pretty much
invincible into heaven when your
oversized water pistol put the fear of
God me welcome I was ready to throw in
the towel but then I visited a friend of
mine and he helped me remember that no
one is fearless the real heroes they
find a way to rise above that fear make
a difference anyway even if it kills
them in the process hopefully with the
dying part now let my friends go awesome
[Music]
oh there you go I'd give up if I were
you
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah face to the glass do
no [ __ ]
Oh delicious mmm
she's too smart for me self-awareness
from rounding me I think there's hope
for you yet that's rich
who that
[Music]
what I guess yeah person's name at least
that's okay yeah I wasn't a hundred
percent sure but that was the woman who
came up to bury in the weddings like
haha this is a great day or whatever I
remember she gave some very some weird
speech in Africa the crossover never
brought her back or never made sense of
what that was but now she's here so
they're building her up to be something
important I don't know exactly who she
is I think I heard a theory about her
once that was like she's the future
daughter of Barry and iris or something
that'd be pretty crazy and the show's
deal a lot with time-travel so I
wouldn't be surprised if that was the
case I gotta say I'm pretty surprised by
how much I enjoyed this episode
the thought of Barry not being the flash
and then we're just primarily giving the
focus is going to the team without the
flash and Ralph didney becoming the
elongated man the stretchy man of
Central City
normally when that's the setup I'm like
I don't really know how I'm going to
feel about this I often don't fully
enjoy the episodes where the title hero
is away from the team I thought this
episode did it surprisingly well
everything that went on with Ralph I've
never noticed it until now but I kept
thinking of Jim Carrey and at one point
he says groovy and I'm like he does have
this Bruce Campbell type of personality
and then I remember Jim Carrey saying
then he got a lot of his personality
from Myer Bruce Campbell so this is
really all just a Bruce Campbell thing
but he's doing his own thing that he's
bringing to the table and I really
enjoyed everything they did with his
character they've slowly been allowing
his character to grow I remember there
was one specific episode where I was
thinking man is this guy he's just gonna
just be annoying if he just stays this
way and then in that exact episode they
started having him be more vulnerable I
enjoy watching him I actually believe
him a lot in his more sincere more
serious moments like that talk that he
had with Barry in prison I thought was a
great moment for Barry I don't know how
people are really responding to the idea
of Barry being in prison I've been like
there's something more they could deal
with his storyline there there was one
criticism I had towards seeing Barry in
prison it kind of feels like because
Barry's in prison the writers don't
really know what to do with him or how
to make his storyline feel super
important over there I feel like there's
room to do that and maybe with the
introduction of Big Sur or Dave there'll
be a lot more personal meaning to his
story inside of the prison is these are
the powers in prison is interesting to
me I keep feeling like he could just do
whatever he
he could just avoid the cameras and
avoid people look at him and he could
still do cool flash stuff whatever he
wants in a way I did feel like he gave
away his powers to those bad guys that
he beat up they have to know in some way
he was his way to fast they might
recount how the events went down and put
together that this guy has some type of
meta power
cuz even though I really liked that
scene I thought it was cool man and they
mastered the effects of Barry being able
to move in regular time while everyone
else is in slo-mo cuz that looked great
but going back to Ralph's story I
thought it was in tune with his
character to learn that he's not
invincible that a lot of these heroes
have that part of their journey where
they think they're invincible when they
discover their powers you know that was
a very human touch to have that he gets
really hurt and he gets terrified and
it's almost crippling him from going
back out into the field after he has a
speech with Marion he gets his suit and
I like his new suit
I think his new suits pretty dope I
didn't think you could actually come up
with a really cool live action suit for
this guy but I like the way the new suit
looks it definitely looks better than
the gray one but its whole storyline
kind of reminded me of something I would
see Jim Carrey and there are elements of
it that reminded me of the mask and even
going up against trickster and prank
play by Devon gray and Corey more
familiar oh she was just like how Mark
Hamill was trickster she was praying in
the 90s television show that's cool to
do like learning facts I thought she did
a great job some of the lines feel a
little tired and weak in terms of like
the stupid jokes they make you know that
trickster makes but of course that's
just--that's trickster that's the
character I wouldn't expect something
super smart to come out of his mouth but
I like these as the Oedipus complex it's
so true because the whole time I'm
watching them they are really creepy
together you know they don't do anything
technically creepy it's just the way
they interact feels this makes me feel
very uncomfortable I thought when terms
are keeping Barry in prison and focusing
on the other characters story of having
to save the city without Barry I found
that really interesting I was engaged by
it Ralph had me cracking up at some
points man this guy gets funnier to me
pretty much every episode at first I
didn't really love him but every episode
I'm really loving the guy more and more
and I feel like there's room for Barry
stuff to be even more interesting I like
seeing Barry as sort of adjusting to
being a prisoner I like his facial hair
I like that he gets to be this like
little hero inside
the prison yeah I mean now that this
part's established we got to get the
devote stuff going again we got to get
the Devo stuff going again but right now
I'm enjoying where the flash has been
going in the different directions has
been taking it's experimenting and I
like experiments all right guys we you
can catch my full reaction over at
patreon along with all our other TV show
reactions we're gonna start doing some
TV show reactions over there that we
might not even be able to do YouTube
cuts for because that's just the way how
a lot of copyright stuff tends to work
out but you can catch our full reaction
over there right now for the flash and
also you can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell to
get notified every time one of our
videos is up and also download and
follow us on the Stardust that we use
that thing planning